êtes vous favorable à la reconnaissance
de la filiation des enfants nés d'une
gpa à l'étranger c'est la question qu'on
vous pose ce soir sur lefigaro.fr depuis
ce matin exactement après que nos
confrères de france info ont assuré
qu'une circulaire s'apprêtaient à le
faire et que le patron de la république
en marche a fait cette déclaration
oui c'est ce qui a été annoncé ce matin
ils deviendraient les enfants du père et
de la mère
aujourd'hui la situation dans laquelle
on est une situation qui est
formidablement hypocrite puisque seul le
père d'honneur de spermatozoïdes est
reconnue et ses enfants sont dans des
situations qui sont parfois intimement
douloureuse devront classer aux fans de
l'homme je les perds à l'étranger seront
que seront reconnus oui alors on précise
que ces enfants sont déjà un reconnu
c'est la filiation avec le parent qui
n'avait pas donné de sperme qui n'est
pas reconnue parents d'intention comme
le disent les textes alors toujours est
il que la chancellerie et en particulier
la ministre de la justice nicole
belloubet ont démenti nicole belloubet
plusieurs reprises
alors on est dans le flou et les rêves
les élus la république en marche aussi
le semble aussi en tout cas entendre la
présidente de la commission spéciale en
charge de la bioéthique qui était
l'invité hier ici même du toc ministrère
on est bien dans ce qui concerne la
bioéthique sur une évolution de la
société entre ce que la science et la
médecine peuvent ce que la société peut
est prête à accepter
je pense je suis intimement convaincu
que la société est prête à accepter la
pma mais qu'elle n'est pas prête à
accepter la gpa alexis qu'est-ce qu'il
faut croire qu'il faut croire qu'ils
mois mme parent est frappant c'est quand
même que toute cette affaire sa patrie
ça fait quand même d'aider des mois que
les opposants le pm à 10 mètres à son
erp et mayala gpa c'est automatique
ce qu'on fait pour les unit faudra le
faire pour les autres hommes
tout cet enchaînement et se produira
comme ça et ça fait des mois et des mois
que le gouvernement devenait du mais non
mais non ça n'a rien à voir surtout ne
vous inquiétez pas ça sera pas comme
quand on a fait le pacs puis le mariage
le mariage puis l'adoption l'adoption
puis la paix mal on va s'arrêter aux
raisins des pma et leurs potes gp a
juste le jour on commence à apm qu'est
ce qui se passe ils nous ressortent la
gpa et on nous fait on le dit à une
circulaire sur la gpa alors maintenant
ils sont bien embêtés alors il rame en
arrière tant qu'ils peuvent et on nous
dit mais c'était une circulaire pour ne
rien faire du tout moi faut juste qu'on
m'explique pourquoi si c'est pour ne
rien arranger pourquoi on fait des
circulaires si il ya une circulaire
c'est bien qu'ils aient une idée
derrière la tête
donc on est en train de voir à travers
toute cette histoire que il ya un lien
de causalité de de mécanique entre la
pma les gp à ce qui ce se qui est fait
pour faire droit aux désirs de femmes
sera demain fait pour faire droit aux
désirs des hommes comment dire non
comment dire il parler d'hypocrisie l'un
de nos camarades ces journées c'est à
dire dit il dit c'est hypocrite mais
est-ce que c'est pas imminents mans
hypocrite que de dire la gpa est quelque
chose de pas autorisé d'interdire en
revanche on va reconnaître la filiation
des enfants des deux gp en france les
enfants où ils sont reconnus toute façon
ils ont une identité l'état civil ils
vont à l'école ça c'est pas la question
de reconnaître les enfants contrairement
à ce qu'on voudrait nous faire croire
donc ce qui est fait pour les uns là
encore pour la gpa à l'étranger on va
dire on va leur réserver aux gens qui
ont les moyens d'envoyer de d'acheter de
louer des ventres de femmes à l'étranger
n'ont pas ce moment là on dirait qu'il
faut le faire aussi pour les français
parce que c'est une injustice
donc on voit bien que tout ça est
inextricablement lié qu'au gouvernement
fait des pieds et des mains pour essayer
de le dissimuler bannière béatrice est
ce que c'est la lecture vous fait la
même lecture
et si finalement le gouvernement
reconnaissez cette filiation ce que
pensait que ce serait une bonne ou une
mauvaise chose
je pense que la filiation je fais
d'accord avec vous les enfants vont à
l'école
les maires parce qu'effectivement il n'y
a que les pères qui donne le sperme et
c'est les maires qui sont porteuses
les maires sont doivent adopter de façon
à ce que il ya donc une procédure de
façon à ce qu'on soit véritablement dans
une filiation
on va dire reconnu et est tout ce qui
est plus officielle et là on est dans
une poule où le oui pour l'instant parce
que 10ème l'école bellevue tout à
l'heure donc on est dans cette situation
là là où je pense que guérini parle d'
hypocrisie
c'est que de fait ces situations
existent et que on a un certain nombre
d'enfants en france n'est p as avec une
revendication de la part des parents à
skis et cette reconnaissance de la
filiation
il est évident que l'évolution de la
société qui fait que je pense que la pma
ne va pas donner lieu du tout au même
mouvement qui a eu au moment du mariage
pour tous je ne le vois absolument pas
apparaître
d'ailleurs le mariage pour tous après ce
cessez grande manifestation il ya des
quelques photos que vous remettez plus
personne ne semble décidé à revenir
dessus comme ça avait été dit à ce
moment là c'est la société évolue je ne
prends pas de particules pour proposons
sont pas bonnes non ils s'y sont pas
résolus mais ils vont pas remettre un
million de gens ni un million cinq cent
mille dans la rue sur l'histoire de la
pma je n'y crois absolument pas je peux
me tromper bien sûr parce que qu'est-ce
que la société ait évolué comme ça je ne
dis pas que c'est un bien c'est à mal
c'est une constatation et le droit n'est
jamais que la reconnaissance d'une
évolution d'un rapport de force au sein
de la société le droit ils tombent pas
du ciel il est toujours dans une
négociation dans une discussion et les
rapports de force c'est que on arrive
parfois à faire comme j'ai à dire la
peine de mort l'ensemble de la
population était pas pour
et puis a eu un débat qui après plus
personne ne l'a remis en cause même s'il
ya toujours des gens qui voudraient la
remettre en cause de
est ce que vous vous êtes d'accord avec
cette lecture post marxiste du droit de
bien sûr que le droit et s'accommode
avec des retards de l'évolution des
moeurs pour autant le politique n'a pas
se soumettre à l'air du temps parce que
sinon on aurait dit on aurait dit dans
les années 30 l'allemagne est de plus en
plus hostiles aux juifs il faut
comprendre
il fallait par la loi contre la peine de
mort pour la suppression de la peine de
mort le politique ne se met pas à la
remorque donc moi c'est non mais là
c'était oui c'était c'est un problème
c'est un problème de morale je veux dire
qui qui va chercher loin et profonde
dans notre
héritage telle escalade justement c'est
les rythmes notre héritage moral qui est
menacée moi je suis assez d'accord avec
alexis brézet compter dix bons moi
j'étais hostile au mariage pour tous pas
du tout par homophobie puis ça concerne
quelques milliers de personnes étaient
vraiment pas un gros seins parce que je
savais très bien qu'il y avait là bas
derrière chez tremplin p assé la gpa
on voit bien derrière tout ça une espèce
de pantin une primauté absolue de
l'autonomie de l'individu qu'on veut
isoler de tout environnement de tout
racines de toute filiation et ça ça me
fait peur parce que ça c'est pas notre
héritage autant le respect de la vie la
suppression de la peine de mort l'été la
salle n'est pas donc je suis plutôt je
suis très réservé je vois bien qu'ils
sont en train de le préparer et pourquoi
c'est pas qu'ils y croient je crois
qu'ils s'en fichent le président de macs
ont doublement parce que les sondages
ont l'air de dire que nous certaine
majorité qui est franchi et résolu non
mais pour la pme
ils vont faire par étapes et puis après
ils démontreraient c'est vrai vous avez
raison madame par contre dire qu'il ya
des cas d'espèce qui existe c'est à dire
des des enfants qui sont effectivement
scolarisés dont le père où les pères
c'est dans le cadre de couples
homosexuels sont bons donner ou pas leur
sperme et dont la porteuse à l'étranger
n'a pas de statut bien défini mais comme
le site interdit en france
il porte le nom de la mère dont il porte
le nom du parlement d'un père est le
deuxième paiement d'un père voit la
deuxième erreur peut éventuellement
s'ils le souhaitent les adopter bon il
ya quelque chose qui appuient l'idée
l'idée quand même de négocier un ventre
alors des réactions quand vous qu'on
voit d'ailleurs sur lefigaro.fr
direction des des internautes on vit on
va y revenir je vais avoir l'avis de
de christophe nicole new deal est faux
de dire que les enfants de gpa n'ont pas
d'état civil
ils en ont un dans le pays où ils sont
nés et brownie tony diplomatie et maman
je convaincu de la force des mots et des
idéaux et des idées justement d'ailleurs
pour une confusion sur les mots et des
idées on parle de la filiation dans le
cadre de la pma pour le moment là je
crois qu'on a on a la paix là j'ai vu
c'était j'ai vu qu'ils reprennent bien
même la pma les problèmes le ce que ce
qui a été annoncé ce matin c'est que
dans le cadre de la gpa une circulaire
circulaire était en train d'être prises
qui allait revoir les conditions de
reconnaissance de la filiation dans le
cadre des gp a interdit la gpa est
interdite en france mais de fait et des
enfants qui se fait par gpa à l'étranger
votre raisonnement est imparable
simplement celle à laquelle si cathy
sion raid rhétorique qui peut être
remise en cause de ce raisonnement items
sont imparables c'est là c'est la
logique mécanique égalitaire que tout il
a écrit une fois pour toutes il est
évident que la pma va conduire à la gpa
ça ne fait aucun doute
ça ne veut pas forcément dire vous avez
dit les opposants 2 non je pense qu'on
peut très bien être favorable aux deux
je connais un tas de gens qui sont
favorables aux deux et qui considère
qu'en effet comme vous alexis l'un va
conduire à l'autre mais ils ont une
interprétation positive de la chose donc
mais il est absolument évident tout le
monde le sait pour des raisons tout
simplement mes fondamentaux de droit qui
le l'égalité des droits
et donc si deux femmes peuvent avoir un
enfant deux hommes d'avoir un enfant et
si la france ne par hasard ne l'accepté
pas la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme dans les trois minutes règle le
problème mais mon pari est que c'est
tout simplement s'est joué très
politiquement et là on voit très bien
aussi que le sociétal est encore là une
fois de plus chargées comme à d'autres
époques de cacher d'autres enjeux enfin
ou d'occuper l'opinion par voit très
bien sur tout ce qui est grand débat sur
ce si sûr cela ce que ce qui est à mon
avis prévisible c'est que ça ce sera
pour le deuxième quinquennat je prenais
pas les paris donc c'est pas le deuxième
quinquennat
j'y croyais que ça moi je pense que ça
peut aller plus vite
vu ce qu'on est en train de nous
préparer la dire que quand on en est
déjà à faire des circulaires pour leurs
codes
notre enfance ça veut quand même dire
que ça peut aller beaucoup plus vite
alors on s'appuiera sur la jurisprudence
de la cour de justice européenne on se
demande tout cas légitimer la sur la
cour de cassation qui dira ceci prix
mais vous l'avez enfin je sus que je
vous rejoins c'est de dire que si on est
cohérent
il faut être pour les deux ou contre les
deux vols ce qui me paraît absolument
incohérences et la pression du
gouvernement actuel qui en fera l'un et
pas l'autre
ça n'est pas vrai et moi je mon
sentiment qui n'est que mon opinion
c'est que ce qui se joue dans la pma est
grave c'est que joseph et un gravissime
on va voir une sorte de marchandisation
de l'être humain pour répondre à des
fins de droit à l'enfant comme si des
êtres humains pour avoir des droits sur
un autre être humain
jusqu'à preuve du contraire moi je pense
qu'on ait droit sur une chose mais pas
sur un être humain et que donc pour
accomplir ce droit d'être humain sur un
autre être humain on va marchandises et
l'être humain parce que dans la sphère
de la pma c'est ça y est on a dit il
faudra payer les gamètes
parce qu'il n'aura pas c'est donc déjà
on va marchandises et les gars mais bon
les gars mais bon
enfin c'est déjà en termes de principes
ça se discute mais ce qui va se passer
évidemment à ce qui se passe déjà c'est
qu'on paie les femmes vont faire des
enfants
c'est à dire que demain on se crée une
société où les pauvres vont faire des
enfants pour les riches
c'est ça la vérité ou où on va acheter
des femmes pauvres pour que des hommes
riches ou des femmes riches qui veulent
mener une carrière fasse faire leurs
enfants voici ses associés quoi un peu
plus complexe que ça parce que je
connais des cas il peut y avoir des cas
tout simplement heures des frères et
soeurs par exemple il peut y avoir des
cas a mis des couples non mais je vous
assure je reconnais mais surtout la
marchandisation
je vous dire cette affaire elle sera
régulée alexis elle sera régulée il y
aura les régulations mais l'émulation
je parle de régulation du point de vue
juridique c'est-à-dire qu'on mettra des
conditions au père louis et les
conditions c'est qu'on rendra les
enfants quand ils seront pas qu'on veut
c'est déjà le cas aux états unis un
enfant
il n'est pas normal mais on leur en vous
vous rendez l'être humain ce qu'on fait
maintenant on va le rendre comme une
marchandise ne me plaît pas je le rends
c'est ça qu'on le monde de demain c'est
celui là bas je combats sanglants oui
lors je veux je crois que la question
est plutôt anthropologique mais elle est
là au delà de la morale
mais mais mais on y va il faut s'y faire
n'est pas obligée de s'en réjouir
non mais non j'ai pas dit ça mais jeudi
on y va soit pas se faire à tous êtes
vous favorable à la reconnaissance de la
filiation des enfants nés d'une gpa à
l'étranger c'est la question que vous
pose depuis ce matin sur lefigaro.fr
effectivement sur le sur le site il ya
une opposition globale
je cite juste quand même les internautes
je vous donne ma parole béatrice donc
brownie tôt nous dis pour ma part je
pense que les adoptions devrait être
facilitée mais cela reste des adoptions
et on a par exemple sur le forum en
dessous de la question qui est posée sur
le figaro.fr
effectivement tout une toute une série
d'internautes qui sont vraiment
effectivement fermement opposés béatrice
nous dit non c'est légitime légitimé le
trafic humain enfants des droits ce
n'est pas un objet et c'est le premier
pas vers la reconnaissance de la gpa la
gpa toutes ces dérives nous dit iris ou
bien s'agit-il de la filiation
biologique réel ou bien d'une filiation
fabriquer c'est la question de
que pose démocrate et laïque oui
clairement dire qu'il ya longtemps que
les pauvres font des enfants pour les
riches parce que l'adoption
quand on va chercher des enfants en
amérique latine en est on le recommande
package on recueille non mais vous vous
été abandonnée on ne paye pas vous
croyez qu'on paye pas les orphelinats ou
on va les chercher aux fenêtres de
l'argent il en est fait et où l'orgueil
donc c'est vraiment quand je pense qu'on
leur avait dit c'est la première fois
que l'on commencera à ga ça fait
longtemps que c'est qu'on va dire que la
sexualité et la reproduction et l'argent
ont partie liée depuis quelques
millénaires qu'en même temps il est
quand même question dans le cadre de
l'adoption quand même est-ce qu'on n'est
pas dans une situation un petit peu
différente
la mesure où l'adoption il ya
littéralement un abandon de l'enfant et
un couple qui va qui va qui va l'adapter
tandis que là avec ça mais avec ce
système là on est en train de créer
justement ce système de
d'abandon et qui n'est pas le cas avec
la veille avec l'adoption c'est pas tout
à fait système d'abandon si on veut
jouer surfer sur les mots puisque vous
avez une femme qui accepte ce quoi
contre argent soit pas contre argent
d'ailleurs parce qu'il est pas
systématique c'est pas obligatoire 99 9%
des querelles j'ai pas j'ai fais pas de
statistiques donc des catalogues ça
existe ça il ya des entreprises qui font
sa renommée et donc à partir de ce
moment là on n'est pas être tout à fait
dans le dans le même dans le même cas de
ggp a une attitude aussi on n'aurait pas
vu une exploitation de la femme si elle
est si elle est chez elle est
consentante on exploite les femmes
tellement souvent sans les payer que
sinon les exploitants les payant je sais
que je provoque en disant cela j'en suis
tout à fait consciente des limites
pourquoi pas vous croyez que les femmes
elles n'ont pas été exploités des
générations sedan pour faire des enfants
et une raison pour que ça continue
non c'est pas du tout que ce soit une
raison pour que ça continue mais comme
dans nos mairies auront on est un peu
tous les provocateurs mais d'abord ce
sera là ce que je veux ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que moi ce qui
m'intéressait beaucoup dans cet enjeu
c'est qu'on va voir comment va se faire
la ligne de partage entre ceux qui sont
quand même favorable à la paix mère et
ceux qui sont contre la gpa et je veux
dire c'est très intéressant parce
qu'après tout un homme et est également
père par rapport à la femme qui est
maire dont le de l'autre côté donc bah
oui il est père biologique d'un des deux
hommes est père biologique même bateau
que trop quel autre reporter un être
humain neuf mois dans son ventre et
transmettre sa semence une toute petite
différence dans le lien qui est créé
dans un couvent le traditionnel nous
avons posé jamais arrivé de porter à 1
enfin bon c'est la représentation pousse
en effet c'est tout à fait le même
ce n'est pas exact je vous ai pas que
y'a pas le besoin dans l'autre avec 6
cols logique cet enfant vous faites chez
moi non plus ça ne m'est pas arrivé de
commettre une graine que je n'ai pas
souhaité donc mais la seaco logiquement
on sait que c'est un enfant qu'on va
donner un autre coup pour qu'il
connaisse la joie de la naissance et de
la maternité et de la paternité
peut-être qu'on ne le vit pas de la même
façon quand c'est le sien c'est une
hypothèse aurait pas de santé - père de
votre enfant que la mer je pense que la
paternité se construit se construit elle
est moins c'est moins à donner parce
qu'il n'ya pas cette fête de l'avoir
fabriquée de le voir porter dans son
enfin vous déjà devant parents et bien
sûr également pas les balles non même
les je suis pas d'avancer vers la paix
c'est américain perd devient père ou
alors les enfants me faut bien dire les
tout premiers mois il appartenait à leur
mère qui les apportaient un mois l'a vu
ce qui dès la naissance à femme a dû
retravailler l'april congé paternité et
celui-ci doit maintenant qu'avant son
cou une la petite enfance en exil a pas
eu dans le ventre non on était sûr sur
la gpa est là car le meilleur des mondes
de soul et on sait qu'une étape c'est ce
qu'ils veulent ça c'est qu'ils valent
quelque chose de nilis plus profondes
afin d'avoir des cheveux blancs ce qui
nous permettra de ne pas le voir c'est
bien justement on va continuer en tout
cas à voir si c'est l'horizon qui ce qui
se profile avec ses lois et ses
discussions on rappelle donc la question
qui était posée de vous favorable à la
reconnaissance de la filiation des
enfants nés d'une gpa à l'étranger
69% vous pouvez continuer à voter sur
lefigaro.fr et vous avez donc un dossier
à retrouver dès ce soir sur lefigaro
premium sur tous les débats autour de
projets de loi bioéthique et bien sûr
dès demain dans l'édition papier du
figaro et notez également que nicole
belloubet sera retrouvé demain les
l'invité de guillaume durand de radio
classique
interview diffusée en direct à 8h15 sur
lefigaro.fr et figaro life